ils ont une vingtaine d'années et ont
fait le choix de dédier leur vie à leur
pays
jeudi 1er décembre ses vingt jeunes
recrues ont signé leur engagement au
sein de l'armée de terre une évidence
pour maximilien qui rejoint le 4e
régiment de chasseurs de gap
c'était un rêve depuis que tu es obligé
depuis l'âge de 7-8 ans je voulais je
voulais m'engager à l'armée l'armée pour
moi c'est vraiment un métier où
c'est le seul métier où on est vraiment
solidaire avoir un esprit de groupe
c'est ça que je recherchais déjà dans un
métier et puis voilà faire le grand pas
déjà mon père il voulait être engagée là
pas pu vous suivre un peu les traces de
la famille quand sa cellule a toujours
voulu rendre service à tout le monde il
aime bien et puis le truc est bien faire
comment s'appelle tout ce qui est peu de
sport il ya c'est donc là dedans il va
pouvoir s'en donner à coeur joie ce mois
de décembre l'armée de terre a engagé
près de 1200 jeunes dans l'hexagone ils
deviendront combattants de chars
mécanicien même sapeurs pompiers comme
raphaël je voulais un métier ou du sort
si l'on fasse quelque chose d'utile gars
et après il ya aussi le côté c'est un
métier qui est dehors
un métier on bouge beaucoup et c
le sport je vais pas un métier on soit
dans un bureau on est dans une dimension
de vocation est en fait l'armée de terre
a réussi son pari de recruter quinze
mille personnes sur l'échéance 2016 avec
un chiffre près similaire sur 2017 et
nous tenons nos chiffres les jeunes gens
qui viennent nous voir sont
effectivement animés d'une réelle
vocation du service de l'état et du
service de la france cette signature en
mairie de versailles a clos cette année
de recrutement les nouvelles recrues
vont maintenant suivre une formation
militaire parmi les 120 spécialités
proposées dans l'armée